let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right number one speaking of
politics let's get into it in political
news lil wayne has uh
has pulled a kanye west and endorsed
trump here's the tweet from lil wayne
he says just had a great meeting with
real donald trump
besides what he's done so far with
criminal
reform the platinum plan is going to
give community the community real
ownership
he listened to what we had to say today
and assured that he will
that he will and can get it done
uh so i i guess it doesn't that's not
technically a full endorsement but it's
just about and there they are giving the
picture the
thumbs up in the photo though the the
political alliance
trump and lil wayne so lil wayne joins
of course kanye west i want to say 50
cent but i think 50 cent rescinded his
endorsement i might be
i could be wrong i didn't care enough to
read the story but even so this is a
surprising turn of events
plus the rapper lil pump endorsed trump
so trump appears to have cornered the
market on lills
he's got lil wayne little pump uh here's
a little pumps endorsement by the way he
shot out sort of an endorsement video
that i thought was pretty astute
uh listen to this hey all i gotta say is
trump 2020 i look like paying an extra
33 in tax for biting
sleepy joe trump 2020
yeah you know in so many words that's
basically my own argument for trump as
well
one of them anyway i'm a fan of of
politicians taking less of my money
i kind of like that myself and what you
just heard there that is
more insightful easily than any
political analysis you'll hear on cnn
um so you see this kind of stuff and
maybe it gives you hope a little bit if
you're a trump supporter
maybe there are a lot of unexpected so
far uncounted trump votes out there who
knows
there's gonna need to be if trump has a
hope of winning
i think um so i factor all this together
and i'd have to say
that right now because i always i also
get people all the time asking me for my
my prediction what's going to happen
and factoring all this looking at the
polls looking at the rally turnout the
endorsements
everything my official official election
night prediction is this
i have no damned clue not the foggiest
i really have no idea i i could talk
myself into believing that trump
wins narrowly i could talk myself into
believing that trump loses in a
landslide
i could talk myself into a tie i can
talk myself in a lot of different things
so so really whatever happens i will
i won't be surprised but i will be at
the same time
that's my prediction you can take that
one to the bank number two okay crafty
stuff here from
nbc news a big story allegedly the
headline
how a fake persona laid the groundwork
for a hunter biden conspiracy deluge
and it continues a 64-page document that
was later disseminated by close
associates of president
president donald trump appears to be the
work of a fake intelligence firm
so that's really all you're supposed to
read right there fake conspiracy theory
fake story hunter biden loose
associations
that's all you're supposed to do you
read the headline you move on
and you're supposed to think okay well
all the hunter biden stuff is phony
but wait a second let's read the actual
article it says one month before a
purported leak of files from hunter
biden's laptop a fake intelligence
document about him went viral on the
right-wing internet
asserting an elaborate conspiracy theory
involving president
or vice president joe biden's son and
business in china
the document a 64-page composition that
was later disseminated by close
associates of president donald trump
appears to be the work of a fake
intelligence firm called typhoon
investigations according to researchers
and public documents
the author of the document a
self-identified swiss security
analyst named art martin aspen is a
fabricated identity
according to analysis by disinformation
researchers
who also concluded that aspen's profile
picture was created with an artificial
intelligence face generator
okay so
in other words shifting through all that
this has nothing at all to do with the
laptop this is some other
thing that they say it went viral on
right-wing
websites across right-wing social media
i'm on right-wing social media i never
saw it i don't even know what they're
talking about
so this is some other thing no one's
ever heard of
some document no one's ever heard of
from a month ago
that nbc news says is fake for the sake
of argument let's just trust what
they're saying okay fine
it's fake who cares why is this news
no one even knew about this fake thing
nobody was talking about this thing
why are you bringing this up now well
obviously the idea here is to muddy the
waters to get people to
draw these associations between hunter
biden's story and conspiracy theory
they just want those associations there
and so this is just all about getting
that headline out there
so that it also has the effect of of
discrediting in people's minds the
laptop story which again has nothing to
do with
this thing that nbc news is talking
about so
it's a clever trick put out an unrelated
story as a way of discrediting
the real story um
so that's that's all there is but you
know
this this goes to some of my frustration
with the with the hunter biden laptop
thing and i've already shared with you
my my hesitations in general
wondering you know if this is going to
resonate with the voters if the voters
will really care
i think they should care it's a big
story it matters it's a scandal
okay so this is not my assessment of
what people should think more
just just wondering about what they do
think and what they will do
um and also i've i've been worried that
in the closing moments of the campaign
this might be the wrong closing argument
do we want our closing argument about
joe biden to be
about hunter biden even if it is
associated with joe
or are there more direct immediate um
more important arguments about joe biden
that we ought to be making that are now
de-emphasized because of the focus on
how divided
that's a separate thing but the other
problem is this this slow
leak strategy the people that have the
laptop rudy giuliani whoever else has
the laptop or has the information on it
they've been leaking out the stuff
slowly over the course of weeks
and even now you still get these teases
from people in in right-wing media who
say they have the information saying
this is the tip of the iceberg there's
more to come
dude we're three days away from the
election four days
what are you still teasing stuff for if
you have it put it out
i mean what's already been released is
is damning but if you're telling us this
it gets even worse well what are you
show it to us
now it's time to show the iceberg
my fear is that this whole strategy has
been has been handled
horribly waiting way too long to bring
up the laptop
and and taking way too long to get the
information out
probably if you're gonna go this route
they should have dumped all the
information from the laptop
like two months ago before the first
debate before you already had
80 million 80 million people have
already voted i think it's up to now
and there's still information about the
laptop that they haven't told us yet
uh it's just two months ago they should
have put everything out
it gives time for people to sift through
it it gives time for it to
kind of for this narrative to take hold
for people to start second guessing
you know if you want to start getting if
you want
people to start thinking of joe biden as
a corrupt and untrustworthy politician
and i believe that he is
but that's not how most people see him
so if you want then this is a guy that's
been in the public light for 50 years
so if you want to change the way most
people see him
you need to do it in more than two weeks
you need months to do that
anyway so but part of the problem is
this slow leak approach also gives time
uh for the other side to include the
media
to do things like this to come up with a
strategy of of
you know combating it and you're giving
them time as as more information comes
out you give them time it's sort of
easier for them to ignore it or to do
things like this to distract from it
i think that would have been harder to
do if everything came out all at once in
one big avalanche
like two two months ago let's say okay
number three
uh second day of kim kardashian news in
the headlines
much to my shame she says for my
birthday kanye got me the most
thoughtful gift of a lifetime a special
surprise from heaven a hologram of my
dad
it's so lifelike we watched it over and
over filled with emotion
and it is actually a hologram of her
deceased father
here's the hologram you're 40 and all
grown up
you look beautiful just like when you
were a little girl
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day sometimes i drop hints that
i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
piffy
or when you make a big pifi
remember when i would drive you to
school on my tiny mercedes every day and
we would listen to this song together
[Music]
[Music]
who was that man
i am so proud of the woman that you've
become kimberly
and all that you've accomplished all of
your hard work and all the businesses
you have built
are incredible but most impressive is
your commitment to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy okay so that's
that's weird
um i i think get a little creepy but it
gets worse
listen to this part you married the most
most most most most genius man in the
whole world
kanye west yes kanye west
really made a hologram of his wife's
dead father
and had the hologram call him kanye the
most genius man in the world
there's got to be a word other than
narcissism for that this is several
steps above
normal narcissists are looking at that
and thinking wow
they are they are highly impressed this
is like turbo narcissism narcissism
squared
narcissism the deluxe package this is
just
amazing and also pretty creepy of mine i
i i
i would just say to anyone close to me
if there's any
you know multi-millionaires close to me
that are thinking of uh
getting me a birthday gift or christmas
gift pl
please i don't want any holograms of any
dead relatives i
i never want that let me just say that
now publicly
number four andrew cuomo was on the view
yesterday
and let's see how that went governor few
people
uh have a better understanding of how to
manage the pandemic
than you do wait okay stop stop it there
i'm i'm i'm sorry what
he's this is like telling the dude from
fire festival that
few people have a better understanding
of event planning than he does
this is now though if you look at it
another way it kind of makes sense
because you could say that
you need to have a firm understanding of
how to do the right thing if you want to
succeed
in doing the exact opposite of the right
thing
you could argue it takes a lot of
planning and execution literally and
figuratively
to do as poorly as cuomo has done
so maybe that's what she meant i don't
know let's let's go with that though
number five finally this video that i'll
play now uh almost got itself on the
daily cancellation it was very close it
was a near tie
almost got there this is from the media
outlet now this which puts out horrible
cringy stuff all the time but this
may be worse than anything else they've
put out the title is most americans got
smaller tax refunds in 2019
thanks to donald trump listen to this
my refund was about half of what it
normally is we were really
banking on the refund i called my
husband
immediately crying
[Music]
so i went back in and i i checked
everything and then
i started to cry this year i just don't
have a refund
[Music]
my refund was about half of what it
normally is it used to be like 4 000 and
then i got 2 000 this year
but this year instead of getting back
the five thousand dollars right was
expecting and that she and her husband
got last year
the houston mom found they actually owed
the government money
with the birth of new daughter olivia
just three weeks ago
wright says her family was counting on a
tax refund
to cover the cost of her unpaid
maternity leave we were really banking
on the refund because we
you know we love paycheck to paycheck we
can't in a sense
save as of right now with three kids in
college the edny family is now
scrambling
last year they got a ten thousand dollar
refund but because of high property
taxes
this year they owe ten thousand dollars
okay stop stop it again
make it stop just make it stop i mean it
actually
says in the video on the screen it
explains it admits
that in most cases people didn't get a
refund because they paid less in taxes
and had more money in their paychecks
yet we're still getting this
tearful sorrowful complaining video
um so why did they get less
in the refunds because refunds aren't
bonus checks
that's not what they are my god
if you got a lower refund that's a good
thing it means you paid
less in taxes it means you kept more of
your own money
a refund is just the government
returning the money it took from you
as a no interest loan it's better to not
give a no interest loan if you could
choose between giving a no interest loan
or not giving a no interest loan
financially there is no benefit
whatsoever
to the no interest loan loaning the
government money and receiving it back
with no interest there's no benefit to
you
it is better to keep your own money 100
you could invest that money in a million
different ways
or spend it waste it whatever you're
going to do and that's what most people
do with their tax refunds anyway they
just wasted on on crap
um but you could do that with your
paycheck i mean it's
it's there's no advantage really no
financial advantage
now i look i understand the
psychological
advantage the psychological boon of
getting a check in the mail certainly
feels a lot better than mailing one
a refund sort of feels like it's
equivalent to
finding money in the couch cushions
right
it feels like free money but it's not
okay and intentionally trying to make it
so that you get a refund
is like purposefully stashing wads of
cash in the in the couch for the thrill
of finding it later
it's it's one thing to go oh cool five
bucks didn't realize i had this when you
pull it out of the couch questions
that's fine
but taking five dollars and putting it
under the kitchen
as an investment strategy is psychotic
and that's what people do with
withholding they they want they
they withhold more because they want the
refund
just put it in a savings account i mean
you'll get interest that was not a lot
of interest but it's more than you'll
get from the government
have you ever heard of a bank account i
hated some people all the time
they actually tell me they withhold more
so that they get a refund
have you ever heard of a bank that's
what they're for
stop giving the government money for no
reason
this is why we need i i i'm not gonna
get a go off on my uh
withholding thing again but this is why
we need to this is why we need to
abolish withholding
the whole withholding system it'll never
be abolished because it's so convenient
for the guy i mean
it's it's made people happy about paying
taxes
tax day has turned into a happy day for
a lot of people which it shouldn't be
but that's the dastardly strategy behind
the withholding system
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but first
um
i i did want to mention one other thing
not a news item technically but just
something inspiring and beautiful to
share there's been a lot of negativity
so i wanted to share this with this is
something that i haven't had a chance to
mention yet but it's from our trip to
nashville
uh over the weekend and we uh we stopped
at a hotel
as i've as i've mentioned when i was
canceling pets early
earlier in the week canceling my cat and
everyone else's cat
anyway the next morning on the way out
of the hotel i was saying to my wife
that we should go to a cracker barrel
for breakfast and my wife for some
reason somehow was against
going to cracker barrel she was
anti-cracker barrel she was
engaging in all kinds of fake news
propaganda
uh in her attempts to defame and slander
cracker barrel
and then i'm not making this up this is
not photoshop
just as we're walking out and talking
about this
i look up and here's the picture here an
actual rainbow a double rainbow actually
uh
over the cracker barrel sign
look at that amazing this this really
happened this is a sign from god
angels lighting the path hallelujah he
has risen amen
how could you look at that image and and
and tell me there is no god you can't
and yes we did stay at a hotel right
next door to a cracker barrel because
we're a high-class family you understand
and it's also true that virginia has
five cracker barrels
at every highway exit so any rainbow is
bound to hit one
you could say but even so um i still
just enjoy the beauty of it
that is providence that is also god
supporting my side of the argument i
think
and by the way we still didn't end up
going to cracker barrel of course
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content